früher waren sie mal die ganz normale
Feuerwehr jetzt ist Krieg in ihrem Land
und alles hat sich verändert
wir sind unterwegs mit dem
Rettungsdienst der Ukraine zu einer der
Wachen die nur fünf Kilometer von der
Front entfernt ist
der Dienst ist schwer und das hat damit
zu tun dass man immer mit Beschuss
rechnen muss
das kann bis zu fünfmal am Tag passieren
es ist noch nie vorgekommen dass wir
keinen einzigen Einsatz hatten
André soll janikoffers zuständig für den
Bereich kopiansk die Kollegen von der
Wache entwurretschner Arbeiten unter
erschwerten Bedingungen
immer wieder wird das Dorf von den
Russen beschossen
das schwierigste ist dass unsere Leute
in Sicherheit sind wenn es Beschuss gibt
auch unsere Mitarbeiter weil es
wiederholt Angriffe geben könnte
ein Feuerwehrauto ist kaputt das Gebäude
beschädigt
kaum sind wir an der Wache geht er
Beschuss los
so heftig dass wir uns in Sicherheit
bringen müssen zusammen mit den Männern
vom Rettungsdienst
der Weg in den Bunker gehört für sie zur
traurigen Routine
[Musik]
27 erlebt in dem Dorf hat sechs Monate
zusammen mit seinen Kollegen unter
russischer Besatzung ausgeharrt seit dem
Abzug schießen die Russen immer wieder
ins Dorf
es begann ungefähr am 12 September sehr
starker Beschuss und seitdem geht es
weiter und die Intensität ändert sich
kaum
und so verbringen sie die meiste Zeit
zwischen den Einsätzen im Keller
ein Holzofen liefert Wärme
mit Licht sind Sie hier unten sparsamer
jetzt erleuchtet vor allem das
Kameralicht den Bunker wenn es ganz
besonders schlimm ist können die Männer
vom Rettungsdienst hier unten auch
schlafen
das ist unsere tägliche Realität weil
wir morgens mittags abends beschossen
werden wir sind etwa 5 km von der
Frontlinie entfernt sie sehen uns durch
das Fernglas
während des Beschusses bleiben die
Retter im Keller und erst danach fahren
Sie zum Einsatz was ihre Sicherheit aber
keineswegs garantiert
starten und auch dann noch einmal den
gleichen Ort treffen
ruhiger wird nehmen uns die Männer mit
ins Dorf die Hälfte der Häuser sind
zerstört es gibt kein Wasser kein Strom
kein Gas viele Einwohner sind geflohen
weil es regnet erklärt uns andre hat es
wahrscheinlich keine Brände gegeben
eine alte Frau sucht in den Trümmern
ihres Nachbarhauses nach Holz zum Heizen
ich weiß nicht was wir machen werden wir
brauchen Holz das Haus steht ein Dach
haben wir und dann schauen wir mal
diejenigen die bleiben sind die alten
oder die die kein Geld haben um ihr Haus
ihr Leben hinter sich zu lassen so wie
es wird Lana die mit ihren Kindern auf
der anderen Straßenseite lebt
[Musik]
wir werden es immer warm haben die
Kinder haben Eltern die für sie sorgen
wir finden Holz vielleicht hilft uns
jemand oder auch nicht wir können das
aber auch selbst machen wir bleiben am
Leben die Ukraine wird überleben das ist
sicher
plötzlich kommt eine ältere Frau mit
einer Tüte voller Lebensmittel sie war
während des Angriffs unterwegs ich bin
losgegangen und habe humanitäre Hilfe
bekommen Fleisch
von wem haben Sie das bekommen
ich weiß nicht von wem vielleicht von
der Stadt aber wir wissen es nicht
einmal in zwei Wochen bekommen wir
humanitäre Hilfe
wir sind zurück auf der Wache andre
erzählt uns fast nebenbei dass er bei
einem der Angriffe verletzt wurde
Splitter im Bein am Rücken Gott sei Dank
nicht so schlimm das meiste hat das
Feuerwehrauto abbekommen da sieht man
noch das ist das der Einschuss
als ich verwundet wurde da trafen die
größeren Fragmente das Auto und die
kleineren trafen dann die Leute wir
hatten Glück dass dieses Auto direkt vor
dem Keller stand
ist gerade gewartet die größeren
Fragmente sind hier hier und hier unten
eingeschlagen
die Wache ist das was sie in den
befreiten Dörfern die Punkte der
Unbesiegbarkeit nennen ein Generator
läuft die Einwohner können hier ihre
powerbanks Aufladen sich aufwärmen es
gibt Internet Telefon
selbst eine Spielecke für Kinder gibt es
sicher sagt André ist es hier aber nicht
wir bemühen uns das Gebäude nicht so oft
zu betreten nur wenn sich Leute melden
die in den Punkt der Unbesiegbarkeit
rein wollen oder wenn es unvermeidliche
Dinge zu tun gibt in der übrigen Zeit
sind wir im Keller
müssen
André lebt ohne seine Familie hier seine
Frau ist in die Westukraine gegangen
dort ist es weniger gefährlich viel
sicherer als sind vorretschner
ja das stimmt aber meine Frau ist
schwanger und das Baby fängt an sich im
Bauch zu bewegen
und ich bin hier
die Fahrt zurück bringt uns heraus aus
der direkten Gefahrenzone auch in
kupjansk ist vieles zerstört Beschuss
ist hier aber seltener überall hängen
riesige Plakate die den Wiederaufbau
ankündigen wir zusammen mit Europa steht
da
Europa hat das Volk der Ukraine gerade
mit dem Sacharow-Preis ausgezeichnet der
Rettungsdienst der Ukraine wird dabei
ganz ausdrücklich genannt von den
Männern der Wache in kohjanskulich
wissen ob ihnen das etwas bedeutet
wir arbeiten im normalen Modus
natürlich ist es wichtig der
Rettungsdienst das ist eine schwierige
Arbeit
wir bemühen uns mit allem was möglich
ist den Leuten zu helfen sind
Schichtwechsel beim Rettungsdienst
warum der Ukraine Ruhm den Helden rufen
die Männer
in der Nacht dann gibt es auch in
kohjansk den nächsten Raketenangriff
[Musik]